now this is a Monday and I'm feeling I'm
feeling peppy but I have questions okay
the fire-god we've got a lot of sleep
got my coffee got my slow carb breakfast
and I did a crazy workout so I'm all
good now you see my ass I'll be honest
you've seen it in shorts you've seen a
naked it's not bad pretty good dude I
mean it's a little button that it's it's
got it's a high I got a high roller
spinner where I come from
wait he's mean a spinner yeah spinner I
thought you said a spinner because I
would have been I was about to throw up
because I can only imagine what that
means hitter then call me a spinner so
if I was a girl with a guy your spinner
here tweet with a little apple bottom
least opinion in a basket no on a dick
no I know that but you put you'd sit me
in a basket basket so okay so you take a
you take a chain you hang it from the
ceiling and there's a basket you go
let's get this college boy in that
basket
I'm not saying I'd ever want to do this
but I'm saying say let's get this cause
but I'm like no no that you guys all
exposed right and then let's sit him in
that basket with his legs up and then a
guy gets under the basket you know that
happens right this is this is this is
real yeah and then they do you put your
dong in the guys or the gals rumpy-pumpy
okay and then you spin them oh no I
didn't okay so that's what you call it
that's what that's where that's where in
my opinion in my experience it's what a
spinner is you know spinners a girl
typically especially in my yeah you know
sir me to admire whatever is a hot girl
who's small yeah I know spins yes it's
because she's tiny and you can just spin
it well you know that's what active
spinning is it really but I believe the
spinner thing comes from a thing they
used to do in certain parts the world
I've seen those can they put you in a
basket yeah is leather yeah chain or
maybe it could be a a curb and I'd
rather leather because but it's see if
there's a spinner but as we get stuck on
this oh we kick this off cuz um I wanted
to talk to you about fake asses and who
has a fake ass and who doesn't does
Madonna have a fake ass oh that's part
of the current Yvette's Oh cats
Oh try to put catch each on my head yeah
dude we go fake asses do you want to
wait
yeah let's wait for the through you the
current the truth behind Asian baskets
is it oh she's looking that butthole
from there
well yes feet up in the holster swing
there's a big difference there you go
there you go you [ __ ] don't hurt I
don't know bro but that's a bag Oh also
that samurai guy these [ __ ]
don't flare also I bet the girl spinner
I don't feel sick you her spun around a
bunch lately ah no [ __ ] no throw up and
look at that guy though he's intense
that's an M that's a muscular intense
thick legged Asian man that's a that's a
Japanese man and he's got his hair the
way the samurais used to grow it you can
see shaved it's you're like yeah right
there yeah he's about to bust you don't
know that's it's a gift innit um we'll
get into that dude sorry buddy what I'm
sorry too you came in hot yeah you
jumped on the colonel feds kind of
although yeah sorry buddy um your show
debuts this week dude is this wouldn't
stay everybody this Wednesday on ABC the
show is called schooled to me Fame take
it in and raid it highly how do you rate
shows like I know just watch it yeah
that's what that's all they want right
you don't know nowadays because it's all
it's a number so so there are a lot of
numbers they Nelson is it real anymore
right though sculpin Nielsen ratings are
one thing but then now people watch it
later nobody watches TV all that [ __ ] so
we don't know and then it said also um
of it can digitally - does ABC do that -
yes they do do they do it digitally they
do it so every platform you have - and
then they they aggregate a number and
then you know I excited for it awesome I
am excited for it I love doing it that's
a talented group of people let's just
take me out of it you got Tim Meadows
who hasn't stopped working in 30 years
he's been working this kid Brett died
right there just remember he's the new
Bradley Cooper he's just he does it all
you don't look like Bradley but he's
what those guys he does at all he
doesn't he's hilarious he can breakdance
he's a black belt in Taekwondo he just
everything he does is like he's just
good at everything and then there's AJ
who I'm the biggest fan of she sings
Disney girl yeah she's been singing
since she was oh I don't know singing
dancing see hey and she's the main act
yeah yeah so here's what's funny about
when you see like actors that have been
doing it that long and now they're like
27 and they've been doing it since they
were five we had a we had a number where
we had to dance where they had to do
just some hip hop dancing from the 90s
Bret and AJ and I'm like I will see what
happens
well you know they've been dancing their
whole life reading heed they're trained
so all of a sudden you see them and you
go well you dance you dance so well that
it's taking me out of the [ __ ] show
so you know it's gonna be good I think
it'll be fun that's Wednesday night
Monday night buddy that's weird with
Network having the Goldbergs after the
Goldbergs between Goldberg is a modern
family that's correct
I'm called the sweet spot called the
sweet spot if you're a doughnut you're
the cream filling that's right that's
right
some get yourself with some cream get
you some Kris why do you think Bryan
Callen curry gets you just say cream
that gets yourself some cream this there
it is Wow
yeah I don't know they try to do their
own social media ABC that doesn't really
work you know it's not really the thing
is it yeah dude Network show really neat
that I don't know I don't know and I
think it's all changing so rapidly and
you know I'm people trying to figure out
especially network TV friend figure it
out right well look at what Netflix did
to like HBO's all anybody ever talked
about right it was the it's so
interesting how things happen HBO was
when you were an actor especially when I
was doing like Oz or blow a [ __ ] I mean
all through really till 2015 HBO for the
actor was the pinnacle certainly for TV
and they had every great show verrano's
gave all of it was wire and then Netflix
came along and and you just don't hear
people talking about HBO as much yeah
you do do you do especially Game of
Thrones you exactly you got given
Thrones but I'm saying well that was the
way they used to be the you know and now
a Netflix is kind of like because
Netflix has every family with what HBO
has everything with movies and it's
comedy specials and yeah the TV series
but I just bought a smart TV and on my
smart TV on my on my thing I have two
buttons one for Google and the other for
Netflix it's like oh okay
so it's so built-in now to everything we
btv is everything is on digital valid
because there's HBO demand where you can
just spin watching a thing yeah and
Showtime and all that they both have all
the apps you can't have two if you've
been sports head I mean look at UFC now
with the SPM plus the digital platform
yeah if you're not they have a digital
print man you're kind of [ __ ] 100
percent not a percent so the old model
of regular TV making your money off
advertisement it still exists it's still
here but you know it's it's gazer I
don't know I don't know what do you
think are its days numbered or at my
hand I just think I just think they have
to you gotta figure other thing you know
you just gotta figure things out the day
of like the superstar there's like the
rock there's Kevin Hart stuff like that
but everyone has like their niche like
following like there's kind of that
depth now but it's I think it's better
now because that loyal demographic will
buy or watch whatever you put out the
shut is such a loyal fall yes instead of
this mass number she want can do same so
they have ties towards that I think it's
funny it's all article came out and
Rogen's podcasts I mean download so much
she makes a year there there little off
and but people like smart people like
what the [ __ ] podcast make this much
money yeah I guess do this did that come
out last week
oh really I didn't see it but it was
like that is the number I forget his
total like is like over a billion
downloads for the year some crazy like
that
that's [ __ ] you know Rose want to
talk numbers now he called me I'm
supposed podcasts and tons of money
people like what podcasts make that much
the [ __ ] he thinks going on man yeah
it's nuts
it's not I mean everybody all the big
dogs you get involved in it yes it's
exactly man but everyone wants to
podcast dude well luckily we got an
early my friend you have true that dog
you know I'm saying that man just years
ago it's rainy out today you know I just
want to grab blank and snuggle up you
see how it happens you on the rain I
read a book by the window with a cat in
your lap curled up the rain
I think apparently according to a lot of
social experiments causes people to be a
little bit naughty ER have sex
well the
also also also they'll tend to steal a
little more like so if there's an honor
system where you got a bagel people take
a bagel and in the office you're
supposed to put a dollar it down for the
bagel but the rain makes them peel
typically not put the dollar down just
in rain or they'll take someone else's
food when it's raining and the reason
they think is maybe because it's a
little bit you know it's like cloudy so
nobody can see you overed yeah it'd be
an idiot to think you can steal in the
rain getting caught i just--that's I do
all my heist in the rain do I do it in
the night in the night rain demands cold
so we need more body heat I mean this
asides dude that will have to cause
arousal therefore sex I mean snow not
[ __ ] breaking the internet here yeah
I mean I know people who have that that
my friend's girlfriend had that seasonal
disorder depression in the seasonal when
it would rain she simply couldn't get
out of bed oh oh oh the seasonal we call
it crazy yeah at range couldn't get out
of bed yeah when it was cloudy when it
was wasn't sunny it wet so is that a
real thing just a real thing chin DF
seasonal [ __ ] no I don't think I do that
when he's on kratom not where knees on
great oh I mean I guess my serotonin is
not as high when it's cloudy out when
it's sunny it's [ __ ] out you're
driving to work like yeah yeah yes that
but there there is a level of serotonin
in our brains that's natural some people
have it at for seasonal depression I'm
sure it's a real thing he's not
affective disorder when it gets hot out
I wanna [ __ ] is there something for that
well you know what's funny about that
dude when it's when I'm in like Miami in
Toronto the weather when it's like when
it's I swear to God when it's steamy and
it's like icky I want to I want to get
down on me oh no sticky I was born in
that climate I was born in the
Philippines which is very tropical and
they say that you tend to guy kind of
like where you were born you will tend
to that that environment is I've heard
that it might be bro science of course
but signs and certain of seasonal
depression include feeling depressed
most of the day nearly every day
okay well it's just depressing losing
interest in activities you once enjoyed
having low energy having problems with
shaping shock experiencing change awake
feeling sluggish were agitated shack
having difficulty concentrating mm check
feeling hopeless worthless or guilty
well no checked having frequent thoughts
of death or suicide no no check fall in
winter who the [ __ ] gets the proper
spacing I'll my changes in summer who
gets the present summer nobody I don't
know some people can't deal with the the
heat yeah it's like the this guy this
guy who was our guide this yeah you know
he was like not cold at all we were we
were in four layers in the morning and
freezing and he's in a t-shirt I go how
could how are you not cold I finally had
to say it he goes because it's not cold
I was like okay anybody can't deal with
the heat the heat kills him
can't move does he get depressed off it
though no no it's so cloudy I'm just
like I'm me but a little more lazy like
all right know when it's right lead a
little more comfort food you know I'm
saying but when it's really hot the two
things if you're in Boston in the
wintertime you're not going outside when
you drive down the street the streets of
toboggan empty it's too cold it's it's
you people just in what time when I was
in when I was but Stevie and I were and
I think in Boston in January something
whatever was it was really cold and I
and I was like um he goes I go what do
you wanna do tomorrow goes what no
nothing not going anywhere
what do you mean he goes well it's too
it's too cold I was like well honey well
bro I gotta be in Edmonton this week and
Rogan sent me a screenshot cuz where you
going everything a screenshot of the
weather zero and one degree yeah it's
it's it's zero it's one of the coldest
look on a map please where Edmonton is
I've no idea where it's at it's in it's
in the it's in the Alberta province of
Canada it is so cold up there it's also
where Joe Rogan where you would go if
you want to hunt bear Bremen and the
mosquitoes are about the size of your
finger and they'll leave a perfect map
United State the [ __ ] yeah there's
Alberta Saskatchewan it's so cold up
there so British Columbia is all right
cool where's it's just typing map of
Canada chin is that is it yeah but
where's that Minton on the map it's
right there see Alberta all right next
I believe it's it's well British
Columbia will Vancouver's all the way
over there that's what I'm saying see
where admin team is Edmonton
that's what's typed in there you go yeah
there you go there you go you're right
in the middle of Alberta sir
now you enjoyed that it is well excuse
me sir do you see where the you see
where the Yukon and Alaska is you're not
that far away you see where you see
pretty far see where the Arctic is
pretty far none of it do me a favor
Nunavut which is where my boy friend
Will Sasso shot a movie where the Inuit
live where the caribou are it's the
Arctic where polar bear are and Edmonton
by the way Edmonton's also got Grizzlies
I believe and a guy was just was when I
was there an oil worker in Edmonton get
eaten by one he sure did he got eaten by
I believe it was a black bear the black
bear came out of hibernation and he was
like I'm [ __ ] hungry and you are an
oil worker and you're not in your truck
so I will not dude that's what I'm gonna
bring all my beer gear with me
cuz in the mall they might be there bro
you don't know you know is it the
biggest ball in the world I believe it's
the biggest mall certainly in North
America legend can you just see how far
away Edmonton is yeah but I'm just
saying that's how close you are all
Edmonton Mall
it's once a 16-hour flight Edmonton Mall
only two shot miles on the largest
shopping mall in North America yeah
followed by the King of Prussia Mall
23rd largest world Dubai's the biggest
I'll tell you what I wasn't impressed
with that [ __ ] Minnesota mall no
there's nothing to buy I mean all the
exact same stores but stacked on top
yeah you go you go saw on Sylvanas it's
the same stores twice in the Edmonton
Mall you can go shooting range let's
have a [ __ ] shooting or that small
America it was alright I find it so
depressing dude it looks cool if you're
Seth
and if you're trying to molest kids you
like that like the Nickelodeon play area
it looks colorful it is good let me see
a picture that met them all Edward small
has a way they have they have seals and
dolphins I believe they also this is
actually cooler that's Edmonton yeah
goddamn yeah you got yourself a large
pool who the [ __ ] is trying to go on a
slip and slide when there's nothing to
do that's what you do you get a pool
with a thousand people and share urine
and dry clothes in your pool there you
go there's a castle shipping and you can
and people jump into that water when
they're not supposed to cool and then
then like Orange Julius on the sides and
caps and [ __ ] that's right
same [ __ ] buddy I'm sorry all malls are
the same like pall malls are the same
size that's a city with a roof on it and
you can get everything you want you can
get socks flip-flops they sell there's a
place called flips in Edmonton hey it's
one degree can I get some flip-flops I'm
surprised homeless don't live there I
think so in the morning when you do
radio there you'll see people at 6:00 in
the morning
walking the the center sighs yeah
they're they're walking or running
around you know it's odd how I got one
big look at that - that's cool
you guys surf I stay away from those
I've told this story ripped my trunks
off all of Waterworld saw my dick I
don't know yep as a child jumped on the
rent I like to serve them I didn't go on
it and that thing went think in my trunk
that soon it went saw my day really yeah
now you're not going anywhere with that
but you're just surfing is it that's
like it would not be so much fun
no it's cool it is it's cool it's [ __ ]
okay
I mean they got straight-up what water
park do yeah I got a water park is that
hit me if you're a kid this looks like a
blast and a nice can mid thirty-year-old
I don't know what am i doing i skating
ring dude you can go ice skating
they have a beautiful ice skating ring
so do you like to ice skate there it is
right there
micrographs kidding you did yeah you can
actually I skate what ha
yeah bro Denver ice skating I've seen
disney on ice well you would i skate my
papa can ice skate like a [ __ ] can
you do twirls and
no not that good bro hmm those giant
malls are interesting yeah by
interesting I mean depressing
you hate malls though I hate him J sob
will walk all over that mall go in every
store yeah three days browse and touch
touch everything not buy a thing Micah
hunter-gatherer till the last day
he's what we call a window shopper yeah
there's a there's a great great one-man
show called defending the caveman and he
breaks women and men down and he said
hunter-gatherers women gatherers men are
hunters typically right so hunters when
you go shopping a man goes shopping
he has one thing in mind it's got to get
some jeans and he let those jeans gonna
go to the store to the jeans go again I
mean those jeans kill it you leave and
gatherers when they're looking for
berries and fruits you got to touch
things colors you pay attention you put
them in your basket it's clearly like a
delineation it's really mad women like
to shout out though this guy Dave Becker
you told a bigger suck no all right he's
nothing right he's not cuz I'm on both
well you have one option life yes you
have a lot of female energy as big and
strong as you are but for the most part
women like to shop men get exhausted by
at least I do I don't know I know a lot
of dudes who like to shop well I don't
know you hang out with but the point is
typically I'm making a generalization
but you yeah you definitely liked it
you're typically dudes a bit you like
even when you shop don't you have a
mission of what you want to go do you
don't go hind of you know what for some
jeans I might go dub this shirt school
yeah well you like in fashion urine he's
us he's clearly in the fashion no he's
not a great performer but a really good
writer it was a very good it was a
really good the following show Fred
Flintstone vibe there yeah it was the
first almost one of the first times I
ever saw a show that really created a
true was on elimination between men and
women was on Bradley yeah old school
yeah not a great performer he was a
stand-up comic who ended up writing good
writer not the best performer he should
have had somebody else perform it
frankly and he should have been the
writer but yeah he's still alive but he
broke down how men are men men how they
express affection and how they express
love verse
how women do and and Ziya scientists or
something like that or no just comic no
miss comic but a really insightful one
of course nowadays it probably be
picketed by a bunch of feminists
left-wing feminists who you know think
that there's no difference between men
and women other than socialization
you're not allowed to say that there's
biological differences between men and
women anymore cause only cavemen yeah
longest-running solo play pretty amazing
doing the damn thing dude made Bank
that's not him though he makes money off
that forever so wealthy
yeah you write one thing like that
you're you're so wealthy in rent rent
has played all over the world right it's
still done the the so so I don't know if
you know this but the guy who wrote rent
and rent list took the world by storm
right it was like this big steel killing
yeah and the guy who wrote it and I
think he was 25 or something really
young he died of an aneurysm the night
before it opened how old was he
23 well honey if I don't know he died
and his father said to the original cast
you will always take digs and all of
them said you get you will always get a
piece of the show you know and and and
so they they see checks
I believe forever zette yeah rents not
going anywhere they don't have any no
money problem rent in Hamilton they're
not going anywhere
oh boy he wrote him in actors in Mary's
Poppins now yeah
Wren was the first like rent was about
AIDS about being bohemian was based on
La Boheme which is the you know what
bohemian you know what bohemian means
like I'm a bohemian like me a Rap City
you know like I live I live like a like
sort of like my it's like being a grunge
or hippie sort of like you know like you
live in a commune rent is hard to come
by your kind of like you're a gypsy
group of gypsies Boheme dude how about
um did you see Bohemian Rhapsody I
didn't but he won last night yeah he won
Best dramatic actor and it won best
movie Wow do you agree with that
oh he's so good in it I gotta see him
he's good and spider-verse one two
Joseph crunk about the spider-man movie
18 I'm telling you best movie I've seen
all year so uh Bohemian Rhapsody is up
there but those are
- wow I felt bad for your boy Bradley
Cooper I thought he was gonna win I
wanted to win I don't think they let him
win because it's a remake it's not
original they didn't let him win that
makes sense that makes sense
has anyone ever seen Bohemian Rhapsody
so Bryan Singer directed but Bonnie are
nasty [ __ ] he's so good
whoo with these so it's so well done
dude I gotta see it Bryan Singer he's
good as good as it gets
and the who the guy who won I would say
milk Rob Remi Malik Remi all again
Rami Malek Rami Malek he's I was trying
to figure out what ethnicity is cuz when
he was talking I was Indian where's he
from the Egyptian he's Egyptian ship
[ __ ] no [ __ ]
good-looking [ __ ] man dude he
looks like frickin that's awesome is he
a hundred percent Arabic no he's born
here being of Egyptian heritage Wow
he's born raised in LA I didn't know
that but no he's English there's no way
he's English isn't he Egyptian immigrant
parents Wow cool he's born here
his parents are Egyptian ah one is great
is that right
I thought he had an English accent
unless he's making it up man on the
stage I said I'm Sigurd up Valley and
rarely venture in the Hollywood his
father Wow yeah unless he's just kind of
bullshitting
I thought he was for some reason I
thought he had an English accent it's
it's definitely a different accent it
doesn't sound does sound English
wouldn't sound oh maybe I'm thinking of
that he played that character but can
you know Tom Hanks isn't [ __ ] right
I don't I don't know what that word I
don't appreciate that was her goodness
you'll hear it here this is where I was
like I had to look it up myself but he
talks about it his parents being
Egyptian him being one there's only one
thing we needed to do definitely it was
to celebrate Freddie Mercury in this
film he is a marvel there is only one
Freddie Mercury and nothing was gonna
compromise us giving him the love
celebration and adulation he deserves
though he looks like him man he sure
does
hey daddy put the teeth on him yeah how
about everyone was surprised that our
boy best act in the world really
what's the Nardo no leonhart of capital
no Christian Bale Christian Bale
you know most people don't know he his
English accent is oh yeah bro oh he's
such an amazing actor you hide here why
because you want Award for playing Dick
Cheney dude I watched him I've been
watching him in Henry the eighth he was
man that in Empire of the Sun you want
to see Christmas please let him watch
I'll thick his accent is Jim from last
night oh yeah people you know people are
tweeting like holy [ __ ] he's English
oh yeah that's work actor working today
numero uno yeah I think he really is I
think he's that good I think he blows me
away right to make a life out of doing
something that we love right that's
extraordinary thank you for allowing me
to be a part of that for so many years
he's sewing my so brilliant through in a
perfectly good movie in a so-so career
in one speech so thank you for that
advice my love I wouldn't be working
without red penny night tonight so I
have a an observation what that's a fake
accent oh so in England he went to rot
okay and he was about to Hitler's
ruining spitting I'm my favorite actor I
mean he's an experienced Lee but another
wall he's an experienced Shakespearean
actor he's also if you want to see him
in a great movie Empire of the Sun when
he was a kid bring him up on Empire of
the Sun please well bring up another one
for it let's not jump around so much
bring up one where he's talking again
this looks a little bit older see if
it's different yeah in the drunk tank to
being the youngest White House chief of
staff in 11 years
well he this is he's on set of the Dick
Cheney movie oh [ __ ] he's really on
there yeah holy yeah a little bit about
the acting that you have done before
this movie I mean is acting from the
from the first time that you could
answer the question what do you want to
be when you grow up was that an answer
that you gave no no themselves about 10
then I decided though this is pretty
English I mean that's his my sister
mainly she started well she
they don't sing and acting she still
does I don't feel shaking a brother in
West End
yes yes I saw that a couple of times
around poisoning I thought succeed or
lose a fearful I thought why not try it
oh so so he so he's amazing he was even
as a kid he was incredible and Empire of
the Sun you were like oh well this kid
is he was that ace and you're like oh
well he's incredible but what I'm saying
is that there is a in with a lot of
Brits if you come from an upper class or
if you could not even that if you if
you've just been you know an actor for a
long time and you're so good with all
the different accents he can do any
accent at all there's something really
sort of like you know a bit yeah a bit
of a little more a more cognitive tower
little tower yeah that's all it's just
tougher and you see that when Tom is
that I heard I heard I think you said
this or someone said this to about
what's-his-name the guy the shaped head
British guy in all the Guy Ritchie
movies Jason Statham
I didn't suffer this exact same song
over Jason Statham Jason say that might
be a little different because he was I
don't know he was an athlete I don't
know about his background but I'm not
saying but I'm just I'm saying that
there is a you will find a lot of Brits
who grew up speaking one way she which
was a little more posh and then they
yeah then you then they get this sort of
like more of a shame like I came from a
posh easy upbringing so they will mimic
somebody who didn't that I don't realize
he's been that famous that long oh [ __ ]
Jesus he's incredible he was an American
Psycho but he had a long break and you
know Hughes - he was always acting in
England and always doing like you know
things on stage he's incredible and then
and then came over to this side and also
you know he said I don't know if you
ever heard him talk about how he was
basically like I lose weight I do all
these crazy things because I put makeup
on him and I'm gonna I'm an actor and it
doesn't make me feel like a man so I
have to make it hard on myself
essentially
9 to 49 years I love Statham though he
seems like he's like the only guy I see
that looks good with like the shaved
bald shaved
Oh with like the actually balding yeah
it he I think he made his first we all
noticed him on Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels that was the guy
ritchie's thumb yeah you ever see a
movie yeah yeah but he's a legit athlete
legit Olympic athlete diver he's a diver
right yep
that's Jason stays on his wife let me go
ahead and see Rosie hunter if you don't
mind Jesus Christ
former Victoria's Secret model makes
sense
oh yeah okay it's Jason Statham for god
sakes
yeah thirty years old I'm not mad at
Bradley Cooper's wife he's also a
victorious they're not married though
right they have a kid but she's a
Victoria's Secret model
Jason Statham is not wearing cool [ __ ]
outside whatever cool dude yeah he's the
best his wife right now Dan by now good
for him man
yeah so you wanna uh I don't know how we
get out for Dick Cheney he want it I
haven't seen that movie I want to see it
I did tear my hair to say bad here's
really good I'm not a big fan of Dick
Cheney I don't think it paints him in
the best light now these are the winners
yeah he looks so much like [ __ ]
Freddie Mercury man does here he's be
shorter than I thought huh he does looks
funny mom green puck didn't see that one
blink close didn't see her wait Cassie's
anchor forces so green book oh yeah wow
that one best Wow keeps going down best
performance
mommy Malachy best performance actress
Olivia Colman okay
best director Roma there's your boy
Christian Bale one Regina Keane one for
Beth all right best supporter I love
Regina can I [ __ ] love her good the
sort of regime school
or ah she said lollies I haven't seen
that Regina came one she's just in her
wits how long the [ __ ] screams are
core okay I saw Rogan blast out the
marvelous
what is it the marvelous lady about that
damn Adam McKay drug that's the animated
baby spider-verse
Wow oh my girl work for Best Actress on
that show i watch
have you seen bodyguard or no all of
these I don't know you know watch that
how bored are the Lisbeth Sacha Baron
Cohen who's America this is very Michael
Douglas can you go back for a second
yeah Donald Glover one for Atlanta I
mean I mean was I'm sorry I'm nominating
Bill Hader have you seen Barry uh uh I
have not loved Bill Hader though about a
hitman it turns yeah I suppose be really
good gotta watch that all right
Patricia Arquette won oh that's the girl
yep the clip that Stiller one that means
two huh well there you go boom golden
clothes there you go baby ladies and
gentlemen golden frickin globes never
watch him it's a party I'm not invited
to and I said huh man I suck
do you really yep really and the Oscars
make me feel bad about my slide I know
it'd be awesome to win one of those but
it's not a big just to be invited maybe
though huh never been inviting would be
never been nominated never come close to
anything and I've been doing this for 25
years no I mean I'm just being honest
with you it makes me feel bad mom it's
okay it's just you know I'm just in wait
and in a way I'm doing great and all
that you sir McDonald good you do
certain stuff to get in there right like
yeah I tried so hard to be those people
it's not like I didn't try really hard
things like I didn't everything I
couldn't I didn't come close it's okay
it's just it's just the honest truth of
how I feel about myself but you know
what I very successful in other ways so
you have to just
times when you try really hard at one
thing it's interesting you can fall on
to something else and you know it's
great you know just being an actor as we
all know you it's very very tenuous you
you have that Oscar you win that thing
and then you'd go for a long time
without work and you have to love the
process of acting which I guess at the
end of the day I don't love us nearly as
much as stand-up do you think you're
jaded by it though do you think you know
I'm just hurt by it yeah there you go
you know I mean yeah I'm not jaded
though I'm not jaded I think I'm really
not I mean I appreciate determines your
depends like Jada Jada to me does it it
just means like you've been hurt by it
so that's like I said you don't saying
yeah um that's a good question
jaded well but your heart gets broken a
lot in this business which maybe he's
part our life is even older right you
have expectations and and [ __ ] doesn't
go your way which is how it happens for
everybody and that's okay but and so you
know well so so you know what I think
about Jada I think of jaded and bitter I
don't think I'm bitter bitter yeah and
Jada can also be like because you don't
get too excited about anything because
yeah cuz you're here for the business
that's that you're Jade when it comes to
show business yes not I'm always ready
for it to end right so so look I got
this great show it's airs on Wednesday
but I'm always tempered I'm always
temper sound super stoked yeah well you
know you don't want to get excited
because you'll get your hopes will get
dashed yeah I don't know it's weird that
way like this guy was I brought my dog
to the vet
and for his checkup he's doing great and
this guy had his dog this old man he was
there he's very heavy and overweight and
very sweet kind and but just what kind
of dog and he had this little this
little yes - yes
hey sort of kool-aid it was actually a
brown and he was he was just you know he
had in the he had that sort of black
streaks in his eyes just tearing in his
eyes and and he had had cancer of the
ass
he had dog he had adrenal sack
he has aimed the dog a dog the
and well the guy was sitting talking to
me and he had a gut that went down into
his groin right you know that kind of
got the Custis under pound lives that
kind of [ __ ] yeah and so and he loved
his dog and he was a sweet man he was
you know and he and he and his dog was
[ __ ] had had an anal the anal sac or
Sonoma we had a huge tumor and so they
blast it with radiation and then they
gave him chemo and it caught he had pet
insurance but it probably cost 20 grand
he said so they cured his dog
a year later dog comes back and guess
what he can't poo and he goes yeah I'm
trying to wipe his butt but he you know
he pulls away or she pulls away and I
was like your dog I didn't want to say
it I go your dog's got cancer again bro
yeah you spend all that money and your
dog's got cancer again and so when my
dog I cancer I went no not gonna treat
him over it's game over I'm putting my
dog down because I'm not gonna you know
yeah you have a bad person but I just
want him to suffer because you can't
tell but what I'm saying is that I was
just like what's this guy have to do
with Jaden
oh just that like when when when your
dog gets hurt when your dog is sick if
my dog gets cancer I'm already starting
to detach I'm already getting ready for
the inevitable so by the time it happens
I braced myself I feel like that's how I
treat my career like it says if
something good happens I'm like that's
cool but we all know that chances are
this always ends that's all yes kind of
ah yeah glass and me I don't know if
that's good maybe it's bad I don't know
if that's the way to go through life I
don't go through my life usually you
know I'm very positive person I mean I
use impossible to get me down yeah it is
but they don't get excited about just
Hollywood I just acting just acting it's
it bits because it's light ride really
[ __ ] hard and and I'm on a TV show
it's great but I'm not I'm not
cooing yeah I wanted to be that but you
know what I ain't that yeah but no I you
know I'm not doing Christian Bale's yeah
that's like a basketball play I wanna be
Michael Jordan but but also but also
it's also like like I don't know if I'm
an actor on that like I don't know if
that acting on that level in many layers
I don't know if well I don't know if I I
care enough
gotta love it and only it remember I
wanted making shoot no that's not him
remember [ __ ] homeboy start making
shoes is a cobbler uh uh yeah I mean I
ain't that guy damn st. Louis I don't
give a [ __ ] about I want to do a lot of
different things I don't know if so it's
told me I could be Batman I would do
some [ __ ] do some yeah some strange for
some change Batman I know but but I
don't want to do it for the rest of my
life you you'd have a tower shoot one
Batman move right I know you want to
give me the the sequel we'll figure it
out yeah I'm not gonna dedicate my life
to bang you've been on a set you know
what that's like it's it's a lot of
stuff good it's a tough gig it's it's
not that fun some people like a drama
people absolutely love it or that and
everything or they love it or it's the
only thing they do really well and
that's what they should do and I think
it's awesome
Bradley Cooper from my experience
absolutely loves every aspect of acting
and filmmaking yes yes I bet you
Christian Bale Daniel day-lewis absolute
would have to love it like when he loses
that way yeah industry that whole
process you have to ya know it could be
that good in that in just right now
who's the guy who did there will be
blood it's like Kobe Bryant with
basketball he AB sleaze
he [ __ ] bleeds basket yes you can't
it's not gonna get if you just go
through the motions for the money you're
not waking up at 4:00 in the morning
beating everyone to the gym it's crazy
somebody fighting there's some guys who
[ __ ] love it they love it I'd love it
yeah you kind of love training didn't
you still do yeah but fight the fighting
itself no no I was not I didn't annotate
towards it that's how I feel about maybe
maybe acting for me has always been like
I love love stand-up I love writing but
the actual acting for me has always been
maybe a little what fighting was for you
like to be on set and stuff although the
Goldbergs is a total exception and so is
this school show I dunno I don't cut
those caveats don't try that no I do
like I love everybody just said it
doesn't know III know just different
hey maybe though if I was a star and
maybe if I was being asked do big films
with the challenge maybe I'd be like I
love acting
so maybe I'm see again maybe it may
I'm just talking myself into some
[ __ ] here yeah yeah that works for
you though yeah let's jump some kernel
vents wait cat would you this weekend's
work yup just work like the jacket
though Thanks yeah I do like that jacket
too cool jacket very cool very tail
spinach she's always gonna get that
reference I got it
chick go to the doctor now go to the
female of tailspin she's the same jacket
Balu wore the same jacket in tailspin
Paulo click images check out the jacket
on same as cats shiz dude you are not
that one though you are the only one
where he's wearing the Jaguar so you are
so in the fashion that you noticed that
that's he said the girl
no I'm talking about the main character
the the braised rock and I did a cat you
girl has gone too far right too young
no sir dude how do you remember a jacket
on a random cartoon weird you're into
fashion I always have been
tailspin baby hopefully they bring you
back without going into details I was in
the Hermes store ok now what were you
doing in there
I just was in there for the good
question again it's too boring a story
however sir you can help me with this
they have bags there that are oh yeah
now they look like [ __ ] regular
batteries no I mean by regular as it
gets
I know $10,000 Oh $1000 quality bro can
you explain that to me because you are
you I know you appreciate this I I had
to bring the guy over you have to
explain to me how this is the gun oh I
see ok so so so that's $34,000 right
there well the same they'll like so that
Hermes bag how rare it is same as like
having a gt3 or something you know like
there's not a ton of them out and the
quality that goes into it that's $15,000
I know dude that's 27,000 oh there's a
hundred look at that dude with it
there's $130,000 purses man you can
spend some micro crocodile and share
these just
look at that $131,000 what yeah let me
see that
are you into bags purses cut my mom
really is she tries to get me into it
but I'm not very are you more of a
tomboy yeah definitely
like you'd rather get a [ __ ] uh some
wraps to do deadlift than a in a gym bag
yeah and then like got her meds bag
that's a hundred and five bags thousand
dollars but like you're not into like
Gucci and stuff well I feel like I don't
have anywhere to wear it to like all I
really do is like work or go to school
before and then home like I'm not gonna
walk around in a saline bag well I'm
like at the gym or something 131
thousand dollars now bags are [ __ ]
crazy man but IIIi think it's the
ultimate example of how insane human
beings can be that's thirty four
thousand dollars pregnant so now if you
had the money would you buy a bag like
that I mean if my girl wanna yeah that's
what she was into if I was like Scrooge
McDuck rich I don't give a [ __ ] at all
really no why would I give a [ __ ]
these are the men's bags though would
you buy it for yourself that's a men's
bag yeah no I don't need I wouldn't use
it I've no problem like the faint like
the expensive fanny packs and [ __ ]
they're cool to make sense but it's just
not my thing yeah how much are those
fanny packs even if they're like a
hundred bucks that's too much I think
for a fanny pack like probably like
three to four grand for a fanny pack the
freedoms like the Gucci Leather one yeah
oh yeah those really in right now
they're super in right now well I guess
it's like anything else it's a status
symbol right I mean yeah that's bottom
line I mean wow that's 1200 and every
young dude out my other job rocks that
exact Gucci bag that white one
yeah and they wear it like crossbody
yeah that's that's Ross sponsored delete
how's a bit on it's hilarious that's
interesting they're in right now dude
Wow yeah well listen um I think it makes
sense though carry all your [ __ ]
probably how do you need a Gucci one for
1200 probably not but I hate when
stuff's in my pocket that would make way
more
that yeah I have a little marsupial
pouch yeah like a little kangaroo man
room I call that a man Roo he's a man
that your thing dude
I'm just saying if you wanna bet habit
wait like for you wine right like you'd
spend a shitload online I understand
I've never night when I went as a $400
bottle I go III drool yeah yeah yeah
how's that for honors not [ __ ] for wine
like for another call right what I mean
you can spend $5,000 on a bottle of
wisely yeah and to me I taste some acai
taste like that [ __ ] yep
barefoot and it probably does maybe
let's see well again you're looking at
like the age like that's a 1982 château
Lafite you know it's like the amount of
care that went into the wine all that it
goes in the hand stitching there's some
real you know Hermes is real cause it
marked up like a [ __ ] use the hi
Beast behind it of course the demand
everything but then again just try to
get just try to start a company where
you can fetch that kind of price they
can do it right something right yeah all
right what else we got Markham oh wait
we have a dead could've answer no well
jump in zone sure dude all right well
first one cats so with a stuff Madonna
performed with her son a New Year's Eve
party how old is he he's about like he's
in his teens underage all I believe oh
he's only in his teens afraid to be like
40 no it's her six her adopted son okay
yeah she performed on stage with him
sing a song and somebody got a shot of
her ass and it looks dumpy super-sized
oh look at that
why would my Donna do that that's what a
lot of people are asking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that I can't stop watching this
what's going on with her ass her son's
pants the the butt jewel she has got 460
though she's doing it huh
that ass is awful she's hogging the mic
to which I don't give the Sun a little
bit of [ __ ] limelight dude oh that's
her son yeah yeah that's blood
[Music]
damn that we don't have a picture around
the beat your son with that ass out very
dumpy now there's a demonstrating the
Brazilian butt lift and then implants
those would be implants gonna get the
Brazilian they just take fat and ejected
your ass I'm a huge fan of um these at
Madonna thinking about hobbies let's
press Hilton South doesn't take it easy
okay so we can dumpy though innit well
you gotta have the ankles to support it
yeah gonna have that you can't look like
a fleming I find any very very neat
ankles if you have it has the thighs to
utilize vice for strong thighs but i
just--that's they follow the ankles cuz
god's not gonna give you a fat ass and
[ __ ] Jon Jones it's insane like
you're gonna you need to thick cankles
to support the glutes bro yeah you know
I agree I agree with like you you know
what girls look like a [ __ ] cake pop
no but that's also Madonna is just such
a strange bird I bet she is a nightmare
to hang out
and eight I know I know I know I've
known to people that had dated her is
one name Dennis Robin he fed her all the
pipe no I don't know Dennis Robert I
know people who've been there and
actually have good things to say about
her I think I've when she was younger
I've never thought she was that
attractive ever I see the young ones in
the eighties I've never understood it I
think she's amazing amazingly talented
but I've never looked at her like she
was hot it's like a force in nature yeah
super talented that's a response by the
way just really seeking no one's
approval and entitled to free agency
over my body like everyone else thank
you it's gonna be amazing year to 19 has
tag freedom has take respect has shake
no fear hash tag dumper hash tag still
take huge shits hash tag 80s baby hash
tag grow old gracefully or arrays into
the night hashtag no discrimination look
man 60 get you a dumper girl she can't
help herself she's always complete you a
dumper what doctor did you use though go
to the Kardashians doctor although again
it's all the legs tuned it's all in the
attitude you gotta watch the video
vixens who get [ __ ] brazilian
butt-lift yeah they look amazing
I had to talk with this plastic surgeon
Cana my show on Irvine because he's
married to a friend of mine and a nice
look tan when I go I go dude I'm 50 I'm
gonna be 52 talk to me and he goes he
looks at my face cuz I would I would get
Botox here and here first I go yeah but
my eyes my eyes are [ __ ] I got that
chicken skin of mine and he goes yeah
well we pull him up I go and let me ask
you this I go what it changed my look
would you tell I'm he goes I mean I go
no no would you be able to tell because
I mean ultimately I go exactly yeah
never [ __ ] happen I'll never do it
it's not like Bryan ten years from now
anyway I'm not gonna walk it's gonna be
an old guy know I cared you walk in you
[ __ ] like the look Madonna looks
[ __ ] good look at that if that's her
at sixty but that's an older yeah but I
know so many now that I know what to
look for with Botox
holy [ __ ] are there a lot of people
doing Botox everybody I know
women guys as well yes guys in comics no
come on I know yes well I know what a
nerd actors know I've seen comics though
ya know yeah yep
it's I'm like what where they doing it
at their forehead their foreheads yeah
interesting the corners of their eyes
well the corner eyes get rid of the
crow's feet yeah got all the Chrome's
feed yeah man I used to know that
seventh role of is Avast you you it
happens fast does it though yeah life is
long dude well you know what happens is
you get older [ __ ] like oh so so strong
you can have like so my uncle died of
both his carotid our arteries were he
was always healthy his whole life right
but he got tingling his fingers and he
went into the he goes out something's
wrong with me man he goes into and his
his son could tell he wasn't able to
pronounce certain baseball players names
and he's a huge yeah
so he goes into the [ __ ] doctor he's
my fingers tingling the doctors look at
his the you know the carotid arteries
look at his brain scan they go
three-quarters of his brain wasn't
getting blood he went into cardiac
arrest right there you know they say if
you hadn't been in here a day before
well he got in there you know and he
died right there now he was cited in the
hospital yes inviting and the doctor's
office hospital he was six years younger
than my dad seven he was younger than my
dad
and and but it was because his carotid
arteries he had never he got him never
got him checked so check this out
so your carotid artery or whether your
artery can be 15% blocked a month later
it could be 85% blocked you got to be
careful it depends on your chemistry how
do you find that well O'Brien's got to
go check get checked out cuz my mom
tells me she goes yeah by the way and
you're most of the men they have carotid
artery now when they get it fixed they
live till they're 96 but she goes that's
one that guy so Jake one deep thing you
gotta get checked that hello so I gotta
go to get my kuratas checked am and my
other [ __ ] you can get an angiogram
where you drink died and they can see
everything here mark mace well right on
fifty oh dude did you do the fifty
checkup yeah I got the I got my ass
checked I was good they didn't check
everything I got I got to get a sonogram
you know wait now you get your
cholesterol checked you got to get your
yeah yeah because you people die that
way
quickly he's go man I told my girls
grandma just healthiest [ __ ] walked
all-time eats healthy everything small
in shape and [ __ ] start feeling under
the weather skin start turning old
yellow [ __ ] pancreatic cancer yeah
advanced stage yes
and they go what can we do there's
nothing this is the worst kind because
once we catch it's too late once you
catch it cuz you don't have nerve
endings in your pain cuz nothing you can
do it's but they're gonna take the paint
her pancreas out this Justin yeah should
we talk is a tough road yes Deborah and
how old is she 74 that's Chi Yong Yong
yeah my imarco is 73 full of life you
know that's not that's young that's the
worst it going it's just something like
it brain but yeah or maybe it's the best
way quick well instead of like slow with
cancer yeah but but I'll take that at
least want a heads up like when I'm 90
like you let me live a fast you know
nice life yeah we're are the carotid
arteries there right there in your neck
right yeah yeah that's where you don't
want well how did you don't want to be
locked
do I just in his blood cholesterol oh
yes this fatty material yeah he's eaten
fat he always ate really really well
actually he was a complete he was a
complete [ __ ] health an that it's
like how often you go get that stuff
checked out you know yep try it out for
the Milwaukee Milwaukee Brewers as a
pitcher great pitcher
good pitch but with both hands many
health issues run your family cat see my
diabetes mental health issues yes I'm
depression going on
yeah depression bipolar anxiety um other
than that nothing like no cancer or
anything like that Jim what about you
guys cancer anything no we're we're
pretty lucky then we'll cast on the
family you guys do you said you did
right by I'm front diabetes diabetes
twins twins run in the family
yeah but they can do a lot of [ __ ] now
with clogged arteries do a really good
job
you got it you gotta watch it I'm afraid
of that now too man I'm getting older
and I do have tingly sensations and my
fingers sometimes yeah go get checked
out you're supposed to checked out for
your runny nose that's coming this year
ones last time you went to the doctor
and got a full blood panel and a scan
two years ago yeah too bad yeah and they
said you were good when you get to be 52
and then 60 you got to start yes start
check you feel it like you're like you
know I've always been taking my health
for granted I'm just I'm helping you
know my energy and my [ __ ] natural
thing I got good genetics but look man
I'm under the weather right now holding
Cuban food I had the same problem and I
couldn't figure it out I was like I was
in Africa I was on plane but all that
traveling my respiratory system but
there's a cold going around yeah there's
a cold yeah there's a cold my son has
sneaks up on you a little bit I said
yeah I was like no I just got over a
super sick over the holidays yeah got
over it and my son was a little sick and
I woke him like there's no [ __ ] way
I'm getting sick again but boom so funny
I felt the same way same [ __ ] way I'm
in got it got over it got it again do
that thing you're talking about I did it
last night I've been I shoot salt 180
miles I do that too what doesn't worry
what else we got next one oh can we take
you I gotta piss hard yeah oh you guys
aren't waiting ellen degeneres faces
backlash after defending Kevin Hart
during interview yeah she had Kevin Hart
on her show as a guest and prior to him
coming on she actually reached out to
the Academy and wanted to know if they
were so interested in having Kevin Hart
host and she said that according to them
he misunderstood or maybe somebody who
relayed the information to Kevin got it
wrong and they still very much want him
to host the they said that would be
Oscar yes and she was saying how great
it'd be if he was the host now she's
getting backlash because everyone's like
go he'd never apologised the way he
should and stuff a shut the [ __ ] up and
now noise who's freaking gay woman guy
says it's okay hey came out on national
TV was his
or gay icon [ __ ] off man
just ignore this guy you're like I feel
like you're not homophobic anymore you
shouldn't mind apologizing for your past
homophobia again and again and again I
don't want to hear hostile was it me
tell me tell him or how we didn't hear
you need your apology shut the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's just [ __ ] it's just a
little whiny [ __ ] so he apologized
yeah you should do on every it's not
happy enough it is nice I could enough
to apologize and enough but there's so
there's such [ __ ] that who cares you
know fuck'em there's a lot of dudes who
have no repercussions from any of this
[ __ ] that they've ever said so this guy
put Ellen Ellen given homophobes the
ability to say but Ellen said it's okay
is a massive [ __ ] betrayal I don't
care how many sitcoms you'd lost in the
night Wow what a lame okay Ellen you
talk about the pioneer for gay people
every lost major major [ __ ] sitcom
this guy says she's been running away
from it ever since his name is Lawrence
laura dern Barbour [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] who cares about these people it's
just noise yeah I don't know why you
can't make everybody happy and social
media approves it
you're always gonna have people that
take the time to look what she can it
mean it makes money off of this just
heaven do nothing mala Jose what does
that thing just do the [ __ ] do the
host the Oscars and make it funny and
just go like this to everybody who
suffers not Kevin not L now the answers
yeah Oscars in the fan right [ __ ] a dear
another ask you to scramble to get it
together a host who's gonna be half as
good as Kevin the people the gay people
are upset with Kevin like yeah we did it
you did what
yeah it was still worth a hundred
million dollars you awesome he's also
such a good person he's not the enemy
Kevin Hart ain't the enemy if I could
find their real enemy goddamn man and
he's currently reconsidering
I know I hope he doesn't just say [ __ ]
them I should do it go [ __ ] yourself you
try to make the small minority of
crazies happy never do that no never
go [ __ ] yourself how about that what
else we got [ __ ] those people
promised corporations listen to them
yeah so have you guys watched the movie
bird box on Netflix I have it I've heard
about everywhere about it I guess you
guys still you've seen it oh we said no
I know about it oh but ups it's silence
if they make noise they die or see em
they die No
so it's kind of like a quiet place a
quiet place however it's you can't see
there's something like some sort of like
monster out there that I guess
spoiler alert please turn away if you
want to watch this movie
it makes people Brian you're gonna watch
it the first of never know I watch it if
it's it is is it good I heard I heard it
good I heard the past is really good but
the storyline isn't so you can't yeah so
you can't see there is something that's
making people want to kill themselves if
they see they if they lost whatever
well she blindfolds herself and the kids
right yeah it's based off of a book she
blinds she blindfolds herself the kids
and there's a bunch of other people who
walk around the world blindfolded to
avoid seeing whatever it is that is
driving everybody crazy and so people
are starting to do a blindfold challenge
where they go about doing [ __ ]
blindfolded and Netflix had to come out
and see people to stop doing it because
people are trying to like do like
day-to-day things like driving or like
looking while they're play so what I saw
one dude him and his kids were all
together and he's like let's go and runs
and the kid runs into the wall little
baby one [ __ ] what's this video this is
two girls doing it for 24 hours 24 hours
yeah it's kind of its kind of stupid
though it's them walking around they
don't do anything crazy it's just them
like touching boring I um that's hard to
do these [ __ ] are driving are they oh
no somebody else is driving they're in
the backseat blindfolded
it's in my lovely home state it's kind
of lame man and I'm going to a mall I'm
walking around
Maus terrible ideal um yeah you know
what I think everybody's eye just blur
my eyes a little bit just get a little
peek mmm you might be able to blindfold
bro
well they're not shunran I take my black
ball and just kill I die if I see like
just a tiny little bit what's weird to
me is when you have the lights off in
your house or something or like playing
with your friends or your kid your eyes
eventually adapt to the darkness so you
can see yeah and it [ __ ] weird you
can start to see ship and at first like
holy [ __ ] its pitch but I'll son that
[ __ ] nitrogen turns on it's pretty
cool all these girls were idiots and
this is stupid
yeah this is weird when I play with a
girl she was blind no I went to a
[ __ ] date a long time ago with this
girl and she was talking about how her
boyfriend it didn't work out with him
but he was built like Superman
you're so hot I go what was the problem
and she goes he was crazy and I go how
and she goes he apparently she she
thought he was gay she couldn't prove it
but she did say that when she kind of
finally trusted me she said he would be
we're in Vegas and he blindfolded me had
sex with me and then he let his friends
come in like two of his friends come in
and have sex at her party which is all
hot yeah but then she was as she was
getting mindful as she was doing her
thing she could hear me and she's like
so and then she tried to pull her her
blindfold off and I guess the hand was
holding her because I go oh yeah yeah
she's and then she was like later she's
like did you [ __ ] around he goes what No
damn he's [ __ ] a dude nice yeah so
there was some slightly yeah so he was
clearly like me finally home that was
the first bird box challenge or the
[ __ ] job I'd forgot about who knew
bird box challenge so I could do next
year girl blindfolded he was a [ __ ]
stud too he um he was like a big Calvin
Klein model or something
anyway weird what else we got okay
so there are these identical twins who
have gotten quite a bit of plastic
surgery to look more like each other
they want I so big
this is their more natural look
apparently they've gotten work done in
the past yeah and the reason why they've
got work done is because they want to
look as similar to each other as humanly
possible look [ __ ] City shows that
guy yeah and they are both dating the
same guy the guy in the middle okay and
now they want to get married both want
to marry that guy and have kids at the
same time this guy must be laying it
down real problem I was gonna say he
must be like a tit look at his face
right those oh yeah he's got it I'm for
it for real that's that's pretty cool
you get bored Avery wins but the exact
same not be exhausting
wouldn't you what what you want two of
the different well I don't want the same
flavor-wise Biggs Austin I don't know
yeah they're try and get pregnant at the
exact same time so you have to bus nuts
and both I'm pretty same day yeah he's
gotta be having sex with them at the
same time right oh that's weird is it a
little bit for the sisters but not for
him how do you explain that when you go
to school like this is my half-sister
oh you do brother this is them let me
see what we're working set of tits on
the body gonna say they facetune they're
like raisins going on with their eyes if
n I surgery done with eyes are real baby
okay there I see and then they also like
photoshopped it I would marry okay
they're short now you starting to see
next time he's going chinh doan together
yeah now you're starting to say that
there is a lot of work done they don't
really look like that
that guy looks fake whoa who the [ __ ] is
that right that's their mom okay love
you mom also they're English are they
English mom okay let me see the hashtags
this fashion style stylish machine
outfit
hashtag shopping [ __ ] nails hair beauty
beautiful and now what can you explain
when you put hashtags does it mean it
goes out to other
is like
threads the same Cebu put I just said
you search that hashtag you see everyone
that put the hashtag in there
graduations I mean they're all right
cool man yeah there must be five foot
tall yeah they're very short think
they're not working with yeah yeah
sounds like it might be somewhat Maori
they may have some Maori in them you
know who knows with the surgery they've
done who knows but yeah what else we got
was that it for this okay alright I
don't know if you guys remember this
heavyweight UFC fighter his name is
Dennis stun dodge Nick he's a giant John
guy he now owns a club in Sarajevo and
he saw someone Jeremy assaulted and so
he courageous saved her yeah you can see
this right here nice orange carpet
there's a girl walking out right there's
a girl doing her thing drops her stuff
mistake number one never put your guard
down get the scarf out okay putting
multiple layers on okay multiple layers
all chilly though chilly out in Sarajevo
okay now she must be a dancer it's very
late and this random guy just comes out
grab your hair pull down holy [ __ ] it's
trying to rape her the [ __ ] is he doing
oops something bad he's telling her
something it looks like he's trying to
rob her too
you still attacking he's throwing a job
he just threw her phone down he might
know her actually and then this is the
guy Dennis boom punches in the face
takes him down well they just beats him
up he's the [ __ ]
yeah hopefully god damn it was that
pillar in though I like this and it's
perfect can't tell any other end of the
story as he saved her and the girl
didn't press charges she just wanted to
go home
and I guess in this area Syria how do
you say it sorry well there's a lot of
attacks on women damn why it's like
common there so he's like if you're
gonna be in my facility I'm gonna do my
best to protect em don't move yeah
probably [ __ ] that guy up yeah hopefully
what else you got kid all right let's
move under this female UFC fighter yeah
look to go he was on day lead you want
to see that one I'd probably do those
back-to-back exact same but whatever you
think Oh real quick good Adrien Broner
so he has to domestic violence cases and
then he had to go to court the same day
for two different states and he has a
fight coming up in the 19th two nights
next week except he's got to dirt on the
same woman or what no different women
different places but of course since he
can't be in two places on one time he
has to push the other one to do that to
January 23rd how can he be sanctioned to
fight with all this [ __ ] going on well
he did Lee threw himself on top of a
woman at a nightclub forced her to kiss
him he's facing multiplying constant
gross sexual imposition and abduction
well the you'll probably a video of that
since you can't be in two places at once
cuz I was hearing he wants to attend
hold on aging is facing five separate
charges for the two instance he's
convicted all who go to jail for nine
years Chris Potter story bronto also has
a court date in Florida on Jada 2037
from his arrest parent court between all
Bruner's massive fight with Pacquiao set
for gin and Jesus Christ just a hothead
man yeah I heard people say that he's
sort of let's just not there no he
suffers from a cure yes for sure yeah
he's a strange bird man I want us yet
you all right let's just go look at
Pollyanna
No do you see this be no female UFC
fighter hopefully though show that
picture the guy that she beat up so
someone tried to steal her phone she's a
UFC fighter just contain him posted yeah
pretty easy player it's loading up look
that's the guy's face I steal in her
phone she beat the [ __ ] I was beautiful
two-tiered beat the [ __ ] out of punched
kicked joked all that stuff to him
he tried to steal her phone yeah is she
gonna get in trouble for that though no
self defense yeah yeah that's a girl
that dude it's pretty cool man I love
that okay let's take a real McAskill on
the right Dundee yeah especially now
when his face is all swollen
bloody she's so pretty hmm
can't get enough around oh yes a bluefin
tuna sold for three million dollars
joktan zackyoung a threatened the fin
tuna why is he three make it threat
because you know there's overfishing of
tuna I know
612 pound tuna I think they're
endangered right now actually this is
the same type of fish that sugar fish
yeah you say this is the same type of
fish that people eat all while they're
at sugar fish oh [ __ ] yourself some blue
I always have three million dollars that
six hundred and forty dollars Japan um
and it's 600 pounds well the guy that
bought eight the math home he owns a
bunch of different like famous
restaurants there and he his thing is to
always buy the most expensive fish to
always be the one that it's a [ __ ]
big that blue tunas yeah but that's a
that's an older fish so you're gonna get
a lot of mercury here's a video of if
you guys want to see well that's the guy
but he's ballin what's wrong with him
he's just touchable breathing all their
Japanese did its filthy rich sounds like
you need oxygen
yeah well I got I'm trying you have a
calculator my calculator is [ __ ]
downloading my phone damn it what are
you trying to do whoa so 600 pounds I
don't think that's that you get that
much meat but let's say 600 pounds $40 a
pound doesn't make sense
612 pounds right that doesn't make sense
three million dollars I don't know how
to read this you got this guy six
hundred divided by four 600 times forty
you just six hundred times forty do ya
so that would two hundred six hundred
times forty twenty four thousand dollars
no no that's 2.4 right turn the foot see
I'm such an idiot I don't know math Jim
I'm not I can't read it
holy [ __ ] that's like that's like not
even close to three million dollars it's
not even close well I'm sure there's a
markup well it's a $40 it's way more
than $40 a pound it'd have to be scroll
down chin a gazillion more than $40 a
pound for sure what I mean go down cuz
that would be 200 and hold up boy it is
for you boy wait here bill at 5,000 per
fish usually sells for flavor pound this
is more than that this is $200 a pound
you [ __ ] that doesn't make sense
the tuna doesn't cost that much not even
black truffles cost that much so I cry
[ __ ] on this I cry complete [ __ ]
on this is NPR man maybe 12,000 pieces
of sushi though so you're selling it but
maybe this is a special one yeah
special in that it's a fattier tuna and
it's harder to come by okay
that's why they're endangered okay and
this guy likes to buy this the most
expensive possible and they--but it's
like an auction yeah so they probably
what kept going kept going 600 times
yeah dude but that's not that's not how
much this fish costs bro
get over it broke me I still cry
[ __ ] why it's not seen on average
Bryce it's not move on for the love of
God all right do you remember this dude
that you guys thought it was a dime
piece that he wanted like they were
gonna test possibly using fentanyl to
kill him I did still trying to math over
does it do that uh he did some horrific
murders I forgot is that what it was but
then he he was gonna be the first person
to get euthanized by fentanyl oh gosh oh
I should have all that the story play
and you'll see it he ended up committing
suicide instead murder this guy
oh yeah the dime piece what is Scott
Dozier hung himself at his illy state
prison cell the Nevada Department of
Corrections tells 13 Action News he was
found tonight hanging from a bedsheet
tied to an air vent those years
execution has been a subject of a heated
court battle it was this phone twice
before the battle centered around a
powerful drug midazolam the state wanted
to use for a drug made her Alvarez say
the state secretly obtained their drug
and they did not want it used to came
Dozier the judge sided with a drug maker
the state filed an appeal with a Nevada
Supreme Court last year to move this
execution forward none of this matters
so so let me see so what did he do that
I'm actually hung himself no what did he
know together he killed some young girl
for what I remember I remember
camera
'icarly going that whole thing I think
the majority of there is murder of a
dude and then he chopped them up to
found in plaster dinner in North Phoenix
oh he set up a drug deal or something
those who received 20-year sentence for
killing Greene after my ex tried to
Nevada a stiffer so multiple people had
killed a few evil rough guy alright
let's end this on a high note though
this little dude we've been getting
tagged I've been getting tagged with
them like crazy this asian dude his
name's chin all right I'm just killing
it in middle school so he's a middle
school
[Music]
is he really good or something check it
out
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently has good floaters I don't get
the point though is this not racist
are we just excited because he's Asian
that has to be the reason because
there's so it's not like you've seen
Shasta know he's also shorter than the
other guy he's not
yeah is he's shorter I was Asian so you
know you know racist
it's just what not we expect to be see a
high and people are rooting for him he's
an underdog weird that that goes viral
though how many points it's always it's
only 100 points or something I don't
know looks like six but it's always that
when Asians do something cool it's like
oh my gosh you leave it a big deal for a
while they caught their call miss Qin
sanity Qin sanity men was Linda - ah -
guys I am paid linda jansson he's been
happening fighting the kid for a hot
second now man oh yeah that's good
that's good steel black kids white kids
you had all kinds of people cheering on
for an Asian kid yeah all right so I'd
say the opposite of races you guys play
beautiful show of it [ __ ] on his
floaters man you know why you got a shot
of floaters are white kids I'll see a
celebrate that Oh obviously he's Asian
and he's asians apparently not supposed
to hit floaters I don't know what the
big story is there has to be something
you can score you can move is he
mentally challenged or something why is
this guy I know you mean like you have
to be something there is a thing that's
all it needs there's a sauna you learn
on the bench all the time yeah is it
like a Rudy story it might be a Rudy
things just like a regular looking
there's no way that would nerdy there's
something here chin you don't look into
a pro there has to be something going on
here how much can you look into a little
dude doing nice floaters why do you have
a problem with an Asian guy I don't have
a problem I don't know why it's a
curtain nice floater otherwise it's
going viral it's good with floaters
while not doing anymore makes a little
beasts expects short Asian kids to be
good with floor that's probably it it's
a short asian kid he's he's athletic
seven six fifteen year old he looked at
he looked athletic he looked atletic the
seven six when you're seven six you
don't have much long his name is chin he
became middle school hoops legend
alright that's the video we seen but
doesn't say why that's probably why they
just think people like Asians can't play
have you guys played basketball with
Asian people growing up a lot were they
good no there has to be I don't get it
did not play at all thing comes in like
you ever seen the kid who he is mentally
challenged to come to just rains three
yeah yeah this kid looks like he can he
can move but these guys are actually
playing again but he's about 5 foot he's
for three following the kid he's playing
a super short now he's a tiny tiny boy
and it's everywhere and I'm not sure
exactly if there's a three foot six okay
so that makes there has to be something
he's got good floaters did you said it
it's rare that somebody can you know
he's using a much smaller ball than
normal but still I don't man alright
anyway I would love to figure out what
it is people send it to us yeah
hopefully hey guys do me a favor if
you're in Austin January 31st February 1
to albeit cap cities you come out and
see me I'm bringing some heat back on
the road dude I got a road writen new
[ __ ]
I'm excited that's where I'll be I'm in
San Diego sorry
Feb 7 8 9 come see me there at American
comedy club and freeze my tail off this
Thursday Friday Saturday next Saturday
is my special San Diego two shows those
are damn near sold out oh the new one
for you guys Ontario improv January 31st
through favorite second get tickets for
Bryan myself t5k calm you'll be at the
comic strip in Edmonton Mall of America
yeah they'll find me do you t fat cake
on this the park kid route